aléjate en google
tras 16 años de la era merkel este
miércoles comienza el gobierno del
socialdemócrata olaf scholz el nuevo
canciller juró el cargo junto a sus
ministros hoy estoy deseando empezar con
el nuevo cargo espero con ansias
trabajar con este equipo y hoy se marca
un nuevo comienzo para nuestro país voy
a hacer todo lo necesario el nuevo
ejecutivo será el primer paritario de la
historia y contará con ocho mujeres y
ocho hombres se le conoce como la
coalición del semáforo por la unión de
socialdemócratas liberales y verdes el
partido del canciller contará con siete
ministerios los verdes tendrán cinco
carteras como economía y energía
mientras que los liberales con cuatro
oficinas tendrán la vital de finanzas
este gabinete nace después de 59 días de
negociaciones tras los comicios del 26
de septiembre en este tiempo también han
establecido la ruta de gobierno aunando
sensibilidades sociales ambientales y de
incentivación de la economía
destacan ambiciosas ideas como la
descarbonización y modernización
económica abrir el voto a los jóvenes de
16 años avanzar en políticas de igualdad
con la autodeterminación de género y
ofrecer facilidades para obtener la
nacionalidad además la primera medida
consistirá en subir el sueldo mínimo de
96 a 12 euros un reto después de la
aplaudida era merkel quien considera que
tras la llegada de la pandemia alemania
se enfrenta al mayor reto de su historia
desde la segunda guerra mundial
[Aplausos]